foreign
[Music]
Brett before we get into any of the meat
of the week people have not seen you on
the Reuben report I had to double check
this I cannot believe it since November
of 2018 that's like six lifetimes ago
for me so I don't know how that happened
I'm glad to have you back Jay's been on
many times especially since covid can
you just get people caught up on what
has been going on in the world of Brett
Weinstein in these last couple years
real quick and then we'll dive into
everything else
yeah pretty much uh everything has been
going on I'm glad to be back on the
Reuben report great to see you Dave uh
and congratulations of course on the
major transition in uh in your life
um right that's the California to
Florida transition that's what you're
talking about right you have to be
careful when you say transition these
days right no no I didn't mean to cast
any aspersions uh oh okay okay maybe we
should do pronouns just to be certain
but
um in any case yeah I don't know exactly
how to catch uh your audience up I will
say I think if I was last on in 2018
then your audience might remember me as
a uh well either a a famous non-racist
or a famous racist depending upon
whether they're on the blue team or the
red team
um but it's been quite a ride obviously
2018 is before
the so-called coveted pandemic and the
coveted pandemic turned my life upside
down once again Heather and I uh took on
an entirely new role as terrible people
who have come to believe unforgivable
things and anyway that's been awful but
um you know there's now been a lot of
water under the bridge I guess we are
now in the post pandemic times headed
towards a an election that will no doubt
be a uh the polite word would be
catastrophe that's what I'm expecting
all right Brett you're kicking us off
with a certain set of energy here let me
let me set up why I wanted to have you
guys on together because actually last
time I saw you I have seen you privately
since 2018 the last time was uh was with
Jay it was at Ron desantis's covid panel
this is probably probably about four or
five months ago so we finally got to
reconnect there and gov Governor
DeSantis basically put together a panel
to discuss vaccine injuries talk about
mandates what are your rights what
Floridians can do to fight back against
the against big Pharma and all of that
now the reason that I wanted to have the
two of you on together this particular
week was obviously the hot story uh was
this brouhaha on Twitter between Dr
Peter Hotes and Joe Rogan so for
everybody that didn't fully pay
attention to all the minutia of the
details let's start where this whole
thing started which was when RFK Jr
Robert F Kennedy Jr was on Joe Rogan
last week and then that will set up
everything else so let's take a look at
22 000 people got the vaccine twenty two
thousand and they have six months of
data some of that is unblinded but it's
six months
and during that six month period in the
vaccine group one person died of covid
and in the placebo group two people died
from coven
so that allows Pfizer to tell the public
and you know FDA to tell the public oh
this vaccine is 100 effective
okay so obviously there was a two plus
hour conversation going on between Rogan
and RFK and then Dr Peter Hotes uh who
has been a big proponent of vaccines
throughout the years often changing his
feelings on vaccines and their efficacy
along the way as many people did uh he
tweeted this out and he's a multiple he
has had multiple appearances on Rogan
which made this so interesting he
tweeted out this Spotify has stopped
even sort of trying to stem Joe Rogan's
vaccine misinformation it's really true
Anna Merlin just awful and from the
online attacks I'm receiving after this
absurd podcast it's clear many actually
believe this nonsense to which Joe Rogan
replied Peter if you claim what RFK Jr
is saying is misinformation I am
offering you a hundred thousand dollars
to the charity of your choice if you're
willing to debate him on my show with no
time limit so Jay I want to start with
you because most of to the people who
have seen you on my show and from the
things that I talk about here are
vaccine skeptical certainly against
mandates and and I'm proud to say that I
did not get vaccinated and I and I never
certainly wanted to force anyone to do
anything uh with their bodies that I
wasn't going to force myself to do
you've been very outspoken about all of
this but the reason I wanted to have you
guys on together was because I wanted to
talk about the nature of debate when it
comes to science and what academics and
scientists and doctors should be doing
and who they should be debating and
talking talking to and talking about so
actually I'm just going to give it to
you right there and you can just take it
in any direction you want to just start
uh from right there and then we'll then
we'll get into the specifics so it's a
very quick if I were in the room with
RFK Jr in that in that moment I would
have had a conversation with him about
that study because I know that study and
it wasn't what so there's a word in
statistics we say statistically powered
meaning that does it have a large enough
sample size so that you can meaningfully
answer a question
and that study was not designed wasn't
statistically powered to answer the
question of does the vaccine prevent you
from dying
it just wasn't it wasn't aimed at that
now that's a problem like because you
know if you want a vaccine on you kind
of want to know does it prevent you from
dying that's kind of the probably the
most important thing a vaccine could do
um so it wasn't designed for that and so
I would say look uh that's you can say
that but it's a small sample you don't
really can't learn much about that I
think maybe that was rfk's point you
shouldn't be saying that it prevents you
from dying if uh so in that sense I'd
agree with him but I would say like it
does it did have an end point which it
was statistically powerful which was
meaningful right so it was prevention of
symptomatic infection
two months and I found 95 prevention of
symptomatic infection I looked at those
data in in December 2020 and I said to
myself okay well we it's not it's not
designed to see if it stops you from
getting infected
that's not that's different than
symptomatic infection
you cannot get asymptomatic infection
um you you uh you uh it's it's not
designed to deceive it prevents you from
dying and so I said okay well how can we
use this vaccine if I reason that if it
prevents you from getting symptomatic
infection for two months it probably
will prevent you from dying for that
period And I I was very concerned I
still was concerned about the vulnerable
elderly people who do have a relatively
High infection fatality rate so I
recommended using the vaccine for older
people
um for younger people I didn't think it
was really all that necessary I mean
unless you have some particular
condition that your doctor says You're
vulnerable for
um and so I didn't recommend that uh
Tony fauci looked at the same data I
think and somehow concluded that with
with that it would stop you from getting
infected altogether and that's what led
to the mandates because if you know
there's a difference between a vaccine
that protects me versus a vaccine that
protects you my vaccine protects you
right um and so I so I would have I mean
that was so I I did I was opposed to the
mandates in part because it was it
wasn't clear at the time that there was
they would they would have this external
benefit like if my vaccine would protect
you and so why have a vaccine mandate
just doesn't make any sense there may be
other reasons against the vaccine area
but certainly that's the sufficient
argument against the vaccine Med Brett
to that point uh I remember in June of
21 when Joe Biden went on stage and said
if you get this vaccine you will not get
nor transmit cobit I think I almost did
that verbatim I am not a scientist I
don't have the pedigree three that
either one of you have but I just
remember thinking how could he possibly
know that having rushed this thing out
there's just simply no way you could
have enough data on this am I a
clairvoyant or a genius or what's going
on here Brett
uh I don't think we know what's going on
and actually uh I would gently push back
on what Jay just said it uh suffered oh
my God
debate on a podcast I'm going to make a
lot of money right now
um but you know I Jay you are one of the
nicest and most decent people that I
have ever met and I think that decency
is leading you uh to do something
um in error here which is you you're
looking at Anthony fauci and imagining
that he concluded that there was a
reason to mandate these vaccines based
on some reading of the data that neither
you nor I could understand and I think
we have to be agnostic about why Anthony
fauci would have leaned towards mandates
and uh you know just as the opposition
sometimes tries to read our minds uh we
ought not uh read too much goodness into
the minds of Public Health authorities
who did so much harm now as for your
question Dave of course there was no
evidence and we now know that Pfizer in
particular was well aware that there was
no evidence that it was going to block
uh transmission and therefore the
justification for mandates is out the
window completely
and I would also
um point out I Have Become
ever more focused on the obvious
violation of the Nuremberg code that
these vaccines represented and the
coercion of the public into taking them
and it has placed me firmly in the camp
that actually this was not a question of
to whom they should be given these
vaccines were not ready to be injected
into people people who had them injected
were injected under false pretenses and
they they really should never have made
it to market the excuse of the pandemic
allowed Pharma to bring a prototype into
the world that simply was not ready for
human consumption
I think now people know what you've been
up to for the last five years now you
answered the question it was coming to
those conclusions Jay what would you say
about what what Brett just said on that
on that gentle pushback I mean basically
he's saying that fauci's I don't want to
put words in your mouth Brett but in
essence you're saying well maybe fauci's
intentions actually weren't that good
you know so in some ways you guys are
sort of splitting the hairs I don't even
know that it it matters in some sense I
mean for bread bread is right in one
sense I mean I do tend to I tend to
assume the best about the intentions of
other people and often that's not that's
not right I mean I do that partly just
by just my inclination to do it I just I
can't help it
um but also I think that it it allows me
to build Bridges with people that uh um
I don't know maybe it's impossible to
build a bridge with fauci
um I I I I I do think uh Brett's the the
the the that question is really
important right because he was a primary
architect of these policies and if we're
going to do an assessment of what
happened we have to we have to try to
understand his his State of Mind along
with some of the other leaders like
Rochelle wolensky uh my primarily I
don't I don't uh you bring up Nuremberg
but I don't really primarily care about
Prosecuting them or whatever I'm not
that's not what you're saying but I what
I primarily care about is reform we have
to we have to make our Public Health
structures such that uh when something
like this happens again no matter who's
in power the structures prevent them
from doing these kinds of things without
considerable pushback or checks and
balances or something that's that's
primarily what I care about
um and I I I mean I I think
um the model I have in my head is what
happened after the Challenger disaster
in 1986 you know the space shuttle blew
up and there was like an open
commission with this very famous moment
where where you had uh you had uh uh
Richard Feynman the very famous
physicist come to come into the room
says he's he he'd already obviously done
this experiment before but he walks in
has the O-ring that was in the shuttle
dips it in the ice water shatters it
says well that's probably what happened
and that led to huge reforms in NASA
um I'm having this I mean that's the
vision that I have for what can and
should go forward
um but I've been I've got a lot of
people pushed back on me on this and
Twitter and elsewhere saying look I'm
Jay you're naive and I you know I maybe
I am so well
can I follow up on that I want to be
clear I am not arguing that we should uh
take the most cynical view of Dr fauci
either I don't think we should assume
the best or worst intentions I think all
possibilities are on the table from uh
fauci being an absolutely diabolical
figure to him being the most confused
person who's ever walked the face of the
Earth but one way or the other here we
got to policies that were
extremely harmful to the public and
violated the Nuremberg code now
in saying that they violated the
Nuremberg code I am not arguing and I
have been very careful to say this is
not about the punishment of those people
that's a question for others
and I agree with you I would trade all
punishment in order for us to have a
complete understanding of what took
place during covet how we made these
massive errors because as much as I do
think that people who did wrong should
be punished that that's part of how we
discourage it in the future we are in
danger of never understanding what
happened in this phase of our history
and if we don't understand it we cannot
prevent it from happening again
well it's clear to me that that's why
Governor DeSantis brought you both in
for this panel it wasn't they you guys
all weren't sitting on this panel going
we have to put these people on trial and
everything else it was in essence how do
we make sure this doesn't happen again
but now before we get to I want to show
you some clips of hotels and and sort of
unfurl a little bit of the drama around
this but I just want to ask you guys
broadly uh you're both men of science
you're both academics you're at
universities or Brett you're you're not
are you quite you're not at a University
at the moment but you've been at this
University your Exile University Academy
but Jay you're Jay you're still at
Stanford
um what do you think General policy
should be in terms of scientists
debating academics going on podcasts
debating guys like RFK who are lawyers
who obviously know a lot about these
things but maybe you're not specific
experts because that seems to be what
lit this thing on fire like what is the
nature of debate in 2023 online Jay I'll
start with you you
well I okay so I should say the vast
majority of scientists they're just
doing their work and they're not really
I mean I have to tell you so like when I
was when I was a graduate student I
would like I just like to write papers
and because I would like learn things
I'd run I'd like do some math I'd do
some statistics I'd learn stuff I'd
write papers and I would write the
papers and I wouldn't care what would
happen to it if it got published fine
that and if anyone if two people read it
it made me happy
those those scientists people like that
are like the warp and wolf of Science
and there's nothing wrong with that
but at the same time it absolutely is
important for scientists uh as a whole
or certain or to to engage with the
public especially when the products of
science
transformed the lives of the public in
the way that it has during the pandemic
and and then so for for science as an
institution to say oh we were we are so
far above you all plebes that we're not
going to even engage with you
um even a presidential candidate a major
presidential candidate uh where you're
you're beneath us to talk to
well what purpose is science then like
what what if we're if we're not if if
we're when we when we exactly when we're
chained the products of our work change
society we're not going to reason with
you we're not going to talk to you
that's that is absolutely uh beyond my
understanding and I think it's it's
actually quite dangerous to science
because what what apparently a lot of
scientists don't understand is that our
work is supported by the public it's
primarily Sports and it's and it's for
the public we're not uh I mean we make
jokes about Ivory Towers why do we make
those jokes because we're not supposed
to be uh up up up and above we're
supposed to be engaged uh with and if
you don't if you don't have that
engagement of high-level science with uh
with the public the sign the Public's
gonna stop supporting science we're
funded by taxpayer money a lot of us are
um so yeah I just don't understand it
yeah and and interestingly you know Jay
you were one of the first people that I
had on when kovid started because I was
trying to find people that were a little
more skeptical because I felt I was a
little more skeptical it was obviously
very easy to find unskeptical people so
I was like all right let me see if I can
find someone in that discipline I'm
happy to say that that it clearly bored
out to to be at least in the right
direction but I'm not a scientist so
when I bring guys like you guys on I can
hear what you say but I can't fact check
you in real time which is why debate is
important uh Brett I you've been
involved in many public debates over the
years sometimes on Twitter sometimes in
real life I suspect you basically agree
with Jay there right
um I disagree with Jay a little bit and
and you know all right let's do it gosh
another debate actually represents the
better angels of our nature and he does
so beautifully but I don't think we're
in that era you know Jay is one of the
few people who has managed the
incredible feat of maintaining his
intellectual Independence and keeping
his job in the academy right now the
fact that the academy has been throwing
out people who were independent-minded
means that you have institutions which
at best are so riddled with Conformity
that they cannot be trusted to engage in
these debates themselves so the question
isn't really whether or not debate
should be happening in public on
podcasts no that's not the ideal place
for scientific debates it's not the
ideal place to hash out Public Health
policy however in an era when all of the
institutions have demonstrated that they
cannot do their job the fact that we
have retreated to podcasts that they are
effectively functioning like speakeasies
where we can still have those
discussions where we can't have them in
the faculty lounge or in the lecture
hall you know of course it's the right
place to do it if there's no other place
to do it and I would say you need no
better defense than just to Simply look
at Joe Rogan's podcast and see how many
of the things that we have finally come
to accept about covid were aired there
the fact is you can you can belittle him
and you can say he's a comedian and he's
out of his depth but how is it that he's
had so much foresight to bring on people
whose perspectives are now increasingly
mainstream
truth is a Time release pill as I keep
saying over and over again uh hotels by
the way Dr Hotes did not have a problem
going on Joe Rogan's show repeatedly
when he was not challenged in that Joe
was interviewing him similarly to the
way I would interview either one of you
guys uh here's one clip that went viral
after all this do you take care of your
immune system in other ways do you take
probiotics are you cautious about your
diet
um I'm not as cautious about my diet as
I should be I'm a junk food-aholic
actually well that seems like a terrible
thing for your health it is a terrible
thing for my health and something my
wife is working on but that seems
ridiculous for someone who works with
health yeah yeah
sometimes man I just don't get it right
do you take vitamins I don't take
vitamins really yeah wow I think they do
it I don't think they're neither because
most in the American and the American up
hold up hold up you don't think they're
needed while you're eating junk food
well hopefully I'm not only eating junk
food but you know there's a large body
of clinical research on the efficacy of
vitamins especially vitamins D vitamins
I have taken vitamin D for periods but
the recommendation of my internist and
what about essential fatty acids which
are great for your brain fish oil all
these different things that are
fantastic I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
argue with you yeah
you got it you got you got it over me
yeah you gotta listen but it would you
would have a much better argument you're
making my wife stay here if you're
taking care of yourself a hundred
percent instead of but you still need
but you still need your vaccines I'm
sure you do but vaccines aren't going to
prevent cancer no that's true right
that's true there's a lot of diseases or
diabetes or cardiovascular disease of
these diseases are connected directly to
diet right yeah
Brett I think people might think it's
sort of like Superfluous or something to
show that clip but I thought it
elucidated two points one being why
people like Rogan in general right he's
just telling you kind of the average
guy's stuff like vitamins diet exercise
I don't know those seem kind of
important but also I think the uh the
underlying part of that is that nobody
in the medical profession maybe you guys
or the on the academic side we're
pushing those things during covid
everybody was saying stay inside don't
get vitamin D don't go outside closing
gyms etc etc and here you have a guy
pushing vaccines who clearly wasn't
doing the things for himself uh that
might have pushed him in a way to to not
need the vaccine the way he at least
thought he needed it
well you know I don't know what to make
of what happened during the covid era at
some point it became clear that we were
not only getting bad advice but we were
getting the inverse of the correct
advice and the things that struck me
most profoundly was the advice to stay
inside because it was very clear very
early on that this this pathogen did not
transmit outdoors and one does create
vitamin D in the sun which has a
profound effect not only on this disease
but on many diseases so to be advised to
stay inside exactly the place that the
the pathogen transmits itself
when in fact the right advice was go
outside spend time at the beach
socialize at the beach right if the
intent had been to keep us healthy
psychologically healthy then the advice
would have been look figure out how to
do the normal stuff of life in places
where the virus doesn't transmit and
only worry about the virus when you're
inside in a place where air concentrates
and you're dealing with small volumes
and then figure out how to address it
open the window if you're in a car open
all of the windows even if it's winter
turn on the heat and open the windows we
weren't getting that kind of advice so
yes I mean at some level
hotels is beside the point right he is a
wonderful caricature of the insanity
that we were being told for three
straight years right and the reason that
you're seeing this incredible pushback
on hotels is because he effectively
lived unchallenged because of this
incredible architecture that feeds us
propaganda and protects those who are
spreading it and the fact is there are
very few exceptions that are capable of
breaking through that Joe Rogan being
one of them right Joe Rogan both has the
size of audience and frankly he has
accumulated enough wealth that in one
Fell Swoop he could neutralize all of
the objections to hotels confronting
those who would challenge his
perspective and that you know it was a
it was a pulling back the curtain moment
right we saw the man behind the curtain
plain as day and he was wearing a bow
tie
Jay how worried are you that because of
moments like this if something real
comes one day ten times worse than kovid
whatever whatever it is that most people
and I think myself partly included I I
am not going to listen to anybody at
this point because so much of the
institutional what we thought was the
institutional sanity turned out to be as
Brett's pointing out just basically
crazy or bad intentions or bad motives
or certainly bad outcomes
I mean the primary currency of Public
Health is trust
that trust is absolutely vital because
it you know it you can you know as soon
as you've resorted to mandates
essentially you failed right you you
you're trying to force people to do
something that you think is good for
them people are going to resist they're
going to like they're you they're just
you're just not going to get uh people
to want to do the you really for public
health to work uh you know leaving aside
sanitation and all the all the other
stuff that's like you know but but like
on on personal health they have to trust
you like that if they and if they don't
trust you they're not going to listen to
you I mean actually like the so that
that hotest podcast I actually watched
it
um I mean that what hotels was arguing
for which is uh which which is that
parents should should uh inoculate their
kids against measles
and some of these like us some of these
essential childhood vaccines I'm in
favor of that I think it's actually
quite important and you know the reason
I'm in favor of that is because I've
read a lot of the evidence I've re I've
read these debates and I've come away
from it thinking that it's it's it's
it's it's it's it's it's better than
than the alternative where where you
have uh measles because actually which
really does harm children floating
around now we can have a debate about
that but that's but that's that's my
conclusion from the from the literature
right it seemed it seems to me that
maybe there's a a bigger debate around
scheduling when it comes to vaccinations
for children that's a different topic
altogether but I I think that's
something like I wanted to use this to
illustrate what I would make so so the
thing is if I'm going to convince the
public which is not going to read this
literature about this they have to trust
me that I've done my homework and that
if if I'm convinced by the literature in
the opposite direction I will tell them
that I'm convinced there's a new study
that comes up they have to and and that
that trust is absolutely fundamental
because like as soon as you've lost it
why believe me I'm just I'm just a guy
on the internet to them right or maybe
some somebody publishing papers and some
Ivory Tower to them they're not that
they're not you know so I I think
um what you saw during the pandemic was
a violation of that trust from the very
top people right so like you had people
like Tony facial sorry pick on him over
and over but he's perfect like he very
early on he says Mass work our Mass
don't work right he's actually
reflecting in February 2020 what the
consensus of the literature was
fantastic randomized trial said Mass
don't work
a month later he says masks work the
evidence has changed haha I tricked you
because I wanted to save it for uh for
the hospital workers
I mean at that point
I trust him he's already admitted that
he's going to lie to you he's already
lied he's already lied to you
um and that's and then once you've lost
that it's gone I mean so I think that's
the that's the state we find ourselves
in
um American public health has lost the
trust of a vast chunk of the American
public and it is going to be almost
impossible for it to do its work in
coming years and I actually think that's
a bad thing
um although again I've gotten pushback
from lots of people who distrust Public
Health I mean I do think it is healthy
to have some skepticism so maybe there's
some some silver lining in that but
um there's a lot of complicated things
to like talk about and uh if you lose
that trust as public health you're it's
gone like it's going to be very
difficult for it to work I I really mean
what I said I mean the next big thing
could come and it could be 10 times
bigger or 100 times bigger and I don't
know what would convince me that it is
real because of the destructive nature
of what they have done I'll get you guys
on the phone and we can talk about it on
the show but but that is going to be a
problem for an awful lot of people
speaking of fauci let's go back to March
of 22 21 so this is you know sort of
year roughly a year into covid this is
fauci and uh vice president potentially
next president Kamala Harris
Dr fauci thank you for everything you
are everything you do tell America why
they need to get vaccinated when it is
their time and turn well we need to get
vaccinated because we're dealing with a
serious disease we have a vaccine that's
highly effective and it's safe and
that's the thing that's going to stop
this outbreak the information to show
that it's safe and effective is
determined by large trials and it's been
determined by people who are independent
and transparent it's been examined by
people who have no vested interest
except the help of the American people
thank you Dr Falcon thank you man thank
you nice to see you nice vice president
Brett I mean I'm literally laughing as
it's playing because it reads as
propaganda these people have no vested
interest in anything it's vetted they
have no interest they're just good
people I know clearly Jay has the better
angels of people Brett I suspect you
don't
they made a lot of money David I'm also
an economist well first of all I I would
remind people okay we have now finally
after years of demonizing those of us
like myself who've said that the
evidence all pointed towards a
laboratory League we have finally come
around to the moment at which
um they have just simply tried to revive
the idea of a zoonotic outbreak too many
times and people now see through it
but Anthony fauci
is the guy who sent the work from the
U.S to China right he offshored this
work to China to escape a ban designed
to prevent
an outbreak right a lab leak so
to the just the simple fact if there was
one person on Earth who should not be in
charge of public health policies
surrounding covet it's that guy and for
him to be the public face of Public
Health at that moment tells you
everything you need to know something
has gone desperately awry that a guy
whose judgment could be so terrible as
to put us in this predicament in the
first place is also the guy who is
supposed to be telling us what to do to
get out of it and then Downstream a
couple of years we know everything he
told us was wrong not just wrong but
upside down it was the wrong advice from
one end to the other so that is that is
a conspicuous pattern now again as to
why I don't know but I do know that
um the
the question you raised Jay about
the trust of Public Health there is no
trust left in public health and worse
people are not used to thinking these
terms public health is not the only way
to have viewed this pandemic right you
have medicine and you have public health
public health is the population level
analysis medicine is the individual
patient level analysis in this case
Public Health staged a coup on medicine
right it forced all doctors to sing from
the same Hymnal and the fact is what
those doctors ended up doing on behalf
of this deeply confused at best public
health authority was harm patients so
now not only is the trust in public
health at an all-time low but the trust
in medicine is at an all-time low which
leaves us no meaningful way out as you
say Dave next pandemic you're not going
to want to listen to anybody and your
instinct is right go to the people who
didn't get this one wrong
and and by the way as you guys know they
had to make sure that all of the other
Therapeutics and anything else that you
could do they had to discredit it
otherwise they couldn't get emergency
authorization to push this all through
Jay were you sort of following fauci the
entire time and going boy here are the
moments that he kind of failed because
even that that again that was a year
into covid and I just remember thinking
wait a minute wait a minute I'm not a
scientist I'm not a doctor but I know
that this thing from everyone saying
there was nobody saying oh oh uh you
know 50 of the people are gonna die
they're basically saying 99.97 or
something percent of people survive so I
remember thinking well I'm just gonna
wait this out I just thought I will wait
this out I'm relatively young relatively
healthy I eat right I lived in L.A got
plenty of sunshine that was my policy
but were you tracking the moments where
you know he flipped on The Masks as you
said and was emailing friends saying oh
don't mask when you're on vacation don't
worry about it meanwhile he's double
masking at a baseball game for Optics
and all that I mean let me let me talk
talk about a moment that came very close
to that that clip you played right you
remember he was talking about how what
fraction of the population needed to be
vaccinated to get herd immunity first he
said 60 then he said 70 then he said 80
then he said 90. and then at one point
he said well uh the reason I said 60 is
because I didn't think you the American
public were ready for it yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes which which that to me you
that's fireable is that not a fireable
offense as a public it's it is it is it
is gross malpractice as the spokesperson
for public health right so like but
first he got the he got you can't you
can't get hurt immunity with a vaccine
that doesn't prevent infection for a
very long time uh I mean if you get her
immunity he's a very very short-lived
herd immunity uh so so he he got that
wrong he got the science wrong and then
he again admitted to the American public
of making numbers up just to manipulate
them
um I mean he did that over and over and
over again uh I just and I I mean okay
Brett can you can you forgive me I'm
gonna I'm gonna engage in some
Shakespearean kind of kind of like
psycho amateur psychoanalysis of him
because all right because it's inspired
by what you just said so the guy funds
gain of function work he's a proponent
of it there's a major debate in 2012
about whether it should happen he's on
the side of funding it there's a pause
that happens 2014 and he's like signing
off on he asked he and Francis Collins
his boss have to sign off on getting a
function work he signs off on a bunch of
stuff
um 2017 comes and he basically Maneuvers
up a reversal of that pause so that gain
of function work can go on why does he
do it he's not he's not a bad guy right
the reason he does it is because he
thinks we can predict the next pandemic
and stop it by having a vaccine early
and he spent his entire career trying to
get a vaccine for HIV and failed he
wants to be Jonas Salk and uh he hasn't
at the end of his career he's not Jonas
saw
the the virus arrives and then all of a
sudden he what thought must go on the
back of his head what if I'm the what if
I'm responsible in part for this thing
and then he's like I can I need to do
absolutely everything I possibly can to
put the the virus back in the Box in
Pandora's Box gets to just to reverse
time if we possibly can even crazy
things that end up harming things it's
like well if there's any chance of us
stopping the virus we have to do it
right it's it's he's he's he's like this
you know there's a uh there's a was that
Disney cartoon The Sorcerer's Apprentice
like he's he set off the the mops and
like Mickey is trying to like get get
make it make it stop and everything's
flooding and he's just making it worse
right and that's that is my vision of
him that what of him during the pandemic
it's like he can see his the the history
judging him in this harsh way and a
well-deserved harsh way because he made
this very very bad call about the gain
of function work and then about the
lockdowns Brett can I before I let you
check I mean can I just give an even
more cynical version perhaps which is
just that as a as a government
bureaucrat who was drunk on hour and
having literally the entire world turned
to him for answers he was kind of just
making it up along the way I actually
think it might even be a bit more
cynical than what what Jay is offering
well again I think the entire range of
possibilities is on the table I mean
including the one that Jay just spelled
out I I I have also concluded that at
some level he wanted immortality and he
was willing to gamble the health of the
globe on it both in terms of funding
gain of function research and advancing
a uh vaccines to the exclusion of every
other treatment uh policy that's one
possibility was that it was the selfish
desire to be remembered and then there's
also every other possibility which is
that this was some form of uh corruption
and that uh you know he's personally
diabolical but frankly I don't really
care what I care I mean I care but I
don't really care because as Jay pointed
out earlier the real question is about
I mean reform is probably too mild a
word the system needs a full reboot and
frankly we don't have the people it's
not like the people know how to do the
job and the system is bad there aren't
enough people who know how to do the job
of science the job of medicine the job
of Public Health to reboot the system so
we are now in Dire Straits right we just
simply don't have the materials to do it
and worse and unfortunately uh
Jay you point to the evidence on
other vaccines for example
and the problem is I think what we
learned during covid is that we now
don't know what any of the so-called
evidence means because when you look for
example at the work on repurposed drugs
right to test whether or not they were
effective treatments for covet which you
find if you just peek under the hood is
an absolutely systematic attempt to
discredit these things so does that mean
that they do work no but it means that
the evidence that they don't work isn't
evidence of anything at all the trials
were literally built to fail and on the
flip side we see things like Norman
Fenton's brilliant analysis of the
two-week pause before counting people as
vaccinated for the purpose of
determining uh what the effect on on the
disease was and the fact is if you had a
perfectly the inert vaccine that is to
say just saline and you injected people
with it as was done in the trials and
you assumed that anybody who got the
disease in the first two weeks was
unvaccinated for the purpose of your
study you create the impression that
you've got an 83 percent effective
vaccine when all you're doing is
injecting salt water so the point is
these are very basic errors that were
simply not caught either at the academic
level they weren't caught at the public
health level and so the problem for me
as a scientist who has spent a long time
figuring out how to think about complex
systems is you now have a complex system
that where you look at its capacity to
reason through an issue systematically
is completely broken so how worried yeah
how worried are you about that right
because I think a lot of people are sort
of maybe not consciously thinking about
it but I think somewhere and the recess
of people mind people's mind they're
like wait a minute if this whole thing
was nonsense why should I trust that
these studies that they did in 1950s and
the vaccine schedules then and why would
any of it make sense not only yeah not
only are we without evidence but what
was done in the absence of proper
evidence was absolutely ghastly right if
they had injected us with saline and
pretended that it was useful that would
have been far less risky than injecting
people with an untried platform based on
mRNA that takes over your cells and
turns them into a vaccine Factory that
was a radical response to covid it was
not safe even in principle and it should
have been a surprise to nobody that it
had a wide range of unpredicted adverse
effects
well actually listen let's go on that
Jay what do you think of that I mean do
you think that that's a fair statement
that mRNA is not is not safe just in in
and of itself the idea of gaining a
function to eradicate a virus
okay so let me let me answer that before
but I want to First address Brett's
first point because I want I I like to I
guess true reform I'm going to be
slightly less cynical
um I I I think I think that the issue
here is trust right so like science
requires some level of trust but let me
just point out something that Brett said
which I think is really important that
there were scientists that looked at the
evidence and concluded correctly about a
whole range of things skeptical about
certain studies that that's normal in
science right it's normal uh my friend
Johnny needles wrote this amazing paper
in the early 2000s with the title that
most scientific research is wrong
I remember reading that paper at first I
looked at the television there's no way
he's right and then at the end of the
paper which is like five pages long I'm
like oh my god oh uh yeah so so
like I but the thing is like it's based
on trust right but it's also based on
lots of skeptical people looking at your
work and saying you know I'm not sure
you did this right I'm not sure you did
that right and and that it's that in
that conversation that the truth emerges
the the scary thing about what Brett
said and I think he's and he's right is
that is that the the system as we
currently have it uh it's placed vested
interest of certain group of scientists
small relatively small group of
scientists above and beyond above above
everybody else so that that that
conversation among scientists that
skeptical conversation about okay Jay
you did this study and I think he made
this assumption here that's not right if
you make this a different assumption you
get a different result that that
conversation which is absolutely
essential to science uh it was much
harder during the pandemic if you reach
the wrong conclusion
okay so I mean I think we brought you
and I share that concern the question is
how far away are we from something like
uh what size ought to look like I mean
because if you look back inside of the
history we've been through periods like
this we've been through periods where a
small group of people say well basically
have control over the of scientific over
scientific discourse uh I I'm not
convinced that there's nothing to be I
mean I'm not convinced that we're that
far away I think the key idea is
competition
I I think like for instance I think the
enlightenment works because there's
multiple sources of funding for
competing groups of scientists who fight
with each other and they they're
uncancelable
what we have now is a a huge
concentration of scientific power in the
hands of a relatively small group of
scientific funders you know Bill Gates
uh the the National Institute of Health
um as a policy matter if you diversify
the set of funding or built into what
the funding uh competition within the
funding structure so that the centers
themselves compete with each other
rather than scientists competing for the
the favor of the of of the the hype hope
of science then I think you could you
could strike now maybe that's maybe
right you'd say that's a major
restructuring I mean I don't know that
but I think that has to be the the aim
of the direction of of fixing um real
fast on the on the um
MMR vaccines I mean I've read a lot of
that a lot of that not all of it but but
a lot of that literature from the 50s a
lot of those those people that were
restoring those studies in the 50s and
60s were serious people right they I as
best I can tell they were doing the
absolute best they could to try to get
it true and again like remember the
polio trial in 1954 they enrolled 1 and
0.8 million children in a randomized
trial
before they said the polio vaccine
should be used at scale they were
serious scientists working then and they
wanted an answer before they were they
did a real answer
um we can have that again
I think we can have that again but we
just have to be we have to honestly be
honest with ourselves we are worse
scientists than they were we have
fancier technology but we are actually
don't have the right Spirit of science
the way that they did because they they
whatever the answer was they were going
to say it even if even if it was you
know inconvenient and I don't think we
have that spirit in science anymore well
speaking of that spirit in science
that's why I was so glad to see both of
you at this panel that uh Governor
DeSantis convened a couple months ago
and uh Brett I want to play a clip this
is a portion of you on that panel the
message that was given to us by public
health authorities was not just inept it
actually went well beyond that it was
really the inverse of everything we
should have done and because it was uh
forced on us with this strong form of
coercion it
it was widely accepted because people
didn't have a choice but what we don't
talk about is the question of what would
have happened if we had taken a
different path
so Brett what would have happened if we
had taken another path I could probably
be convinced that if we had done
absolutely nothing things would have
been much better now when we see all the
psychological problems that young people
are having it having all of the
depression the the collapse in the
education system you know literally
five-year-olds who are having delayed
speech now because of masks I mean the
litany and the list goes on and on
well I in my mind there's no question
that if we had done nothing we would
have ended up being better off because
what doing nothing would involve is
clinicians figuring out what worked in
their offices and talking over the
internet and at the water cooler we
would have developed protocols for
dealing with covet and the fact is it's
actually a very tractable disease if
we'd really done nothing including not
doing the gain of function research we
wouldn't probably wouldn't have had a
pandemic in the first place almost
certainly
so there's no question that doing
nothing was superior to the uh massive
self-inflicted wounds that we created
with our uh our Beyond inept
response
as to Jay's point I don't disagree with
you Jay about the fact that we can get
back to a proper scientific culture but
where you and I might disagree is I
can't see us doing it in less than a
generation because let you know first of
all we've trained all of the people
whose staff our medical institutes and
the academy and the journals and the
governmental regulatory apparatus we've
we've trained all of these people in
Conformity we've punished them for
standing up we've fired them for doing
it and you can't just simply say to them
oh those days are over now be honest
they don't remember how they don't know
how to do the job and so if you were
going to fix the system you have to
train a new generation that hasn't
learned that lesson and then the bitter
pill is this who's going to train them
what do you think about that Jay I think
it might work at the state level right I
mean that's why DeSantis convened you
guys right how do how do we as
Floridians you know he was saying how do
I as the governor make sure that the
federal government is not going to do
this again I mean do you think it just
has to be sort of a bottom-up micro
level that will work something like that
I mean I I think I think I hear I hear
you Brett I mean I hear I hear the uh
the frustration but I I mean I've met so
many excellent young people as
scientists who who are we you know I
mean I'm biased about the ones I've
trained but even the ones I haven't
trained
um and I I think that that spirit's
there it's innate it's just suppressed
by structures that make it so that you
you you you move forward by by not being
an excellent scientist necessarily but
by like playing the bureaucratic game
better
I think uh and this is my this is Maybe
This Is The Economist in me like if you
change the structures and the incentives
I really strongly believe that it won't
be the same people like the people that
are that are good at bureaucratic
infighting you know Tony fauci is a good
example of this won't necessarily rise
anymore
um it'll be very different but I think a
lot of people enter size especially a
lot of young people understand because
they want to know they want this is an
incredible beautiful process for
learning true things about the way the
universe works right that's why we under
science because it's it's just beautiful
um and uh a lot of people are still in
science like that Brett I think and I
don't believe that we have to retrain
them I think we just have to give them
the right incentives and then they'll do
the right thing
um at least some of them
um yes I don't know that's maybe that's
this is like totally true to form we
keep we keep I'm I'm playing the more
naive idealistic person I mean I you
know I'm gonna I am an economist people
always accuse me being cynical just for
that reason I mean so it's you know
foreign
Jay let me bring up an uh let me play a
clip from you from the panel because you
brought up the other major issue that we
haven't talked about too much here which
is that the censorship machine that was
silencing guys like you or or virtually
anyone that was outside a mainstream
group think on this uh kind of went all
the way up to the top big Tech
government Etc et cetera take a look I
think the centrally important issue that
caused the problems is that we silenced
people
from expressing their thinking
qualified people from expressing their
thinking and as a result the decision
making at the top of the of the of the
country was absolutely abysmal okay I
suspect you agree with that guy
well first of all I should have combed
my hair my mom my mom that's another
thing
um yeah I think uh I I think that that
that's that that science you know it
doesn't work unless you're unless you
have freedom
you know you you have scientific
cultures that try to sort of mimic
science like I I'm like I think like
what happened to science in the Soviet
Union you had one man
who's decided that mendelian genetics
was wrong and then I'm like contributing
in your area Brett um and then and then
um and then like he throws all of the
mendelian geneticists into Siberia and a
huge generation of of of of of uh
Russian starve because of the stupid
science that they're doing right but as
well as in science so he was playing at
science
science can only happen and can only
occur when there isn't that censorship
because who controls it it's going to be
the powerful people that control the
sensor or control what you can or can't
say and it doesn't matter if they're
right or wrong or it just matters that
they're powerful
science needs to have David and Goliath
stories all the time all the time like
it needs to have people at the top being
overthrown in their ideas by the Young
Turk you know mathematician who's like
no Jay you you're you're wrong and then
I'm wrong because of the just the way
the what the evidence says
um and and you can't have that unless
you have free speech
Brett bring us home well uh you know I I
hear what you're saying Jay you fix the
incentives you fix the system and I
agree with that but it's a long-term
proposition and the reason is akin to
what happens if you have a let's say you
have a neurotic cat who's afraid of
strangers and it hides under the bed
when strangers come over right how do
you teach the lesson that the strangers
aren't actually a problem because the
cat's always under the bed when the
strangers are there and if you drag the
cat out from under the bed you increase
its Terror so it thinks it's really
hiding from something real you've got an
entire an entire system
populated by people who have now
actually survived because they did
conform and say things that actually
hurt other people so training them that
this is the moment to reverse that
instinct is not going to work over a
short period of time they're going to
have to be replaced and again
the problem is there aren't enough
people left in the system who understand
how science is supposed to work to teach
a new generation right that is that is a
critical problem and it's not one I hear
discussed very frequently
I guess my final question to both of you
is since what sparked this entire thing
was uh you know hotels basically said
well in essence he has now said it that
he obviously will not debate RFK on Joe
Rogan's show or anywhere else would
either one of you be willing to debate
hotels on this show on Rogan's show or
anywhere else
yeah absolutely happy to have a
conversation with him I guess so but I'm
not really sure what the point is again
I think the reason that Hotes has been
the focus of this is that the system has
protected everybody who was spouting
this nonsense and that we have you know
we've been trying to get that debate and
it was right so I don't even mean to
make it about him actually but in
general you'd be willing to debate other
scientists that take the opposite
position of you on this which you both
did by the way throughout the pandemic
yeah
I don't I also do not think that a
commitment to debate all comers is a
wise idea right there is there are yeah
and there are uh cynical attempts to
simulate debate that are not worth
having
yeah I mean I I do think you need to
have a serious minded person on the
other side right if you're debating
someone who's who's like main job is to
slander you and to you know engage in ad
hominem or or then then yeah that's a
very very different thing even to play
even to play games based on the fact
that the evidence is full of nonsense
the literature says many things that
aren't true and so the point is somebody
can bury you in bad studies all day long
and it doesn't get you anywhere right
um so but but I but I suspect you at
least you both agree that that Hotes is
positioned that somehow RFK is not
worthy of a debate is probably not
correct right of course not because for
one thing he has attacked he's attacked
our rfk's position rather directly and
so the point is okay let's put the two
head to head and then we can decide
who's more persuasive
I mean I think you can solve that debate
problem partly by you know if if I'm
going to debate somebody
um show me the evidence in advance so I
can assess your evidence I'll show you
my evidence and we're only limited to
citing the evidences that we've shown
each other I think that that's kind of
do that in in like uh legal circles or
something like that I mean I think you
could have rules that would make that
for a constructive constructive thing
the key thing is like I mean I'm gonna I
did high school debate I really liked
winning it was it was fun but the
purpose of the debate isn't to win here
the purpose of the debate is to learn
from each other like if if Brett says
something that uh you know we've if we
had it was this a debate I don't know I
don't think it was debated what it was
like with a really important a friendly
conversation where I learned from you
like I just that should be the goal is
like what do we what have we gained from
each other uh rather than winning
because there's no there's no like
winning and means well I I would I would
agree that the ground rules and in fact
the word debate is the wrong word right
debate is an attempt to win and from my
perspective I've sworn off debates
permanently right the correct term is
dialectic and what that means is that
you engage in it to figure out what's
true right Jay if you're right and I'm
wrong I want you to win right I want to
be persuaded because I want to stop
being wrong and the problem is we have
way too much debate where people are
interested in scoring points and they
don't give a damn what's right right so
you know in some sense I probably
shouldn't be using the term debate
because it's the incorrect one
I don't know that's funny I do I don't I
like the word debate I don't know why I
like it I mean this is because I I I've
always liked it helped me when I was a
geeky teenager to learn to talk to other
people more cleanly and try to engage
with them
um you know on on their terms better
um it doesn't have to be a you know Win
Win Lose thing but I completely agree
with the spirit of what you're saying
Brett I think the key thing is you know
if I if you convinced me of something
where I was wrong and you've convinced
me about that I'm wrong and now I adopt
your opinion you've done me an enormous
favor right I think that's the spirit
well my commitment to you too is that
when the zombies come or the aliens are
on their way or whatever's next I will
be very skeptical of the entire thing
but I will invite you two on first fair
enough
beautiful okay uh we're gonna link to
all your stuff down below Brett it's
been way too long we will continue this
in real life and Jay we are both welcome
back anytime Jay we've been doing this
for a while now so it was a pleasure
guys thank you so much great see you
thank you foreign